[Music]
I always felt yeah a forester was
overrated frankly to take an obvious
example never really got it when people
go on and on about graham greene
especially his important books like end
of the affair
I get puzzled I shouldn't be I mean
there's nothing wrong with green and
there's nothing wrong with Forster
either I just feel like what's all the
fuss about
what is all the fuss about damned if I
know frankly I think there is there are
there must be American writers but Dave
Wallace I think is one of them and
probably George Saunders is another who
I don't think the Bret's get at all I
think they're just like why do people
what this is so this is so puerile it's
so easy it's what I don't know what
they're they're thinking or this is so
bratty it's so annoying or it's so broad
or whatever they're saying I think
there's a category of American fiction
that just doesn't cross the ocean so
well and I think that I'm talking about
a strain of British fiction writing a
not inconsiderable strain of british
fiction writing that I don't that some
people just some people this is what a
novel is it's an ianforster novel or a
Graham Greene novel there are living
practitioners in England producing
novels that also today seem like well
this is what a real novelist is and this
is what a real novel is and for some of
us in America you just like say that's
not even a novelist hardly that's sort
of a that's it's an it's a near-perfect
replica of a novel it's um so it's a
taste thing i I think there's a kind of
well-made product that that Forster
pioneered and represents that engendered
a great many very well-made novels in in
England in the 20th century that either
think is like what a novel should be or
else you just throw up your hands
[Music]